ONE OF TONIGHT'S DOCUMENTARY
FEATURE NOMINEES, ALEXANDER
MANUELA, CALLS HIS APPROACH
OBSERVATIONAL STORYTELLING,
WHICH SEEMS LIKE A REALLY
GOOD DEFINITION OF WHAT
A DOCUMENTARY SHOULD BE.
THEIR IMPACT CAN BE
EXTRAORDINARY, WHETHER IT'S A
FULL LENGTH FEATURE FILM, OR A
CELL PHONE VIDEO TAKEN BY A
YOUNG WOMAN IN MINNEAPOLIS BY
THE NAME OF DARNELLA FRAZIER
THAT BECAME THE
CATALYST FOR CHANGE.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR
DOCUMENTARY FEATURE.
“COLLECTIVE,” ALEXANDER NANAU
AND BIANCA OANA.
“CRIP CAMP,” NICOLE NEWNHAM,
JIM LEBRECHT, AND SARA BOLDER.
"THE MOLE AGENT,” MAITE
ALBERDI AND MARCELA SANTIBANEZ.
“MY OCTOPUS TEACHER,”
PIPPA EHRLICH, JAMES REED,
AND CRAIG FOSTER.
“TIME,” GARRETT BRADLEY,
LAUREN DOMINO, AND KELLEN QUINN.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
“MY OCTOPUS TEACHER,”
PIPPA EHRLICH, JAMES REED,
AND CRAIG FOSTER.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU TO THE ACADEMY.
AND THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
INCREDIBLE NOMINEES WHO SPENT
SO MANY YEARS, AND I PRESUME,
A LOT OF TEARS, MAKING BEAUTIFUL
AND IMPORTANT FILMS
AND BRINGING THEM INTO THE WORLD.
I'D LIKE TO THANK CRAIG FOSTER
AND HIS FAMILY,
ESPECIALLY TOM AND SWATI,
WHO OPENED THEIR HEARTS
AND SUPPORTED US EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY AND FED US
AND ALLOWED THEIR HOME TO BECOME
A PRODUCTION COMPANY FOR THREE YEARS.
I WANT TO THANK OUR PRODUCTION
PARTNERS AT OFF THE FENCE,
ESPECIALLY ELLEN WINDEMUTH
AND SAM BARTON-HUMPHREYS,
WHO BELIEVED IN THIS FILM
BEFORE IT WAS ANYTHING.
WE WANT TO THANK NETFLIX
FOR ENABLING US TO SHARE
OUR STORY WITH THE WORLD.
AND THEN OUR INCREDIBLE “OCTOPUS”
TEAM WHOSE ARMS STRETCH
ACROSS THE PLANET FROM SOUTH AFRICA
TO AMSTERDAM TO THE U.K. TO THE U.S.
ROGER AND WARREN FOR BEAUTIFUL
CINEMATOGRAPHY.
DAN AND JINX FOR INCREDIBLE
PATIENCE AND EDITING.
KEVIN AND BARRY AND KYLE
AND ALL THE PEOPLE AT THE REFINERY.
AND THE INCREDIBLE
SEA CHANGE PROJECT,
WHO’S BEEN IN THE BACKGROUND
SUPPORTING US THE WHOLE WAY ALONG
AND CARING SO MUCH FOR THE GREAT
AFRICAN SEA FOREST,
WHICH IS WHERE THE OCTOPUS LIVED.
AND OUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY
WHO PUT UP WITH YEARS
AND YEARS OF TUNNEL VISION.
IF, IN MANY, AND I KNOW THERE ARE MANY
SOUTH AFRICANS WHO ARE AWAKE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT TO WATCH
THE CEREMONY, AND IN MANY WAYS,
THIS REALLY IS A TINY, PERSONAL STORY
THAT PLAYED OUT IN A SEA FOREST
AT THE VERY TIP OF AFRICA,
BUT ON A MORE UNIVERSAL LEVEL,
I HOPE THAT IT PROVIDED A GLIMPSE
OF A DIFFERENT KIND OF RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN HUMAN BEINGS
AND THE NATURAL WORLD.
>> THANK YOU. AND I DON'T HAVE
A LOT TO ADD TO THAT.
PIPPA, YOU COVERED IT VERY WELL.
IT'S A GREAT AND TOTALLY
OVERWHELMING HONOR TO BE HERE.
AND SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO THE ACADEMY AND ALL THE
INCREDIBLE FILMS THAT
WERE IN OUR CATEGORY.
IT'S REALLY HUMBLING
AND AMAZING.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
MY FAMILY, ROSIE AND ISABEL,
AND MY MOM AND MY TWO SISTERS,
JENNY AND JANICE.
I DON'T THINK I'D BE HERE TODAY
WITHOUT THEIR SORT OF LEVEL
OF LOVE AND SUPPORT,
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I THINK THE FINAL EXTRA
THANK YOU FOR CRAIG,
WHO, WHILE IT WAS SUCH
AN ENORMOUS TEAM MAKING
THIS FILM IN THE END,
IT SORT OF BEGAN AND ENDED WITH HIM,
AND IT’S HIS STORY.
AND HE KIND OF SHOWED US THAT
YOU KNOW, IF A MAN CAN KIND OF FORM
A FRIENDSHIP WITH AN OCTOPUS,
IT DOES SORT OF MAKE YOU WONDER
WHAT ELSE IS POSSIBLE.
SO THANK YOU, CRAIG,
AND CHEERS, EVERYONE